green flags what better quality women
look like okay so the old man good
relationship we talked about uh has an
affinity towards strong masculinity she
likes men she's got a good relationship
with her father
that sort of thing the next one i got is
if you get sick does she take care of
you a green flag and a woman is if she
sees that you're not doing well she
doesn't go off in the other direction to
the nightclub partying with her
girlfriends and hanging out with them
she's got your back another green flag
is she stays away from news drama cable
tv
bachelorette type of shows bachelor
shows all that crap generally speaking a
green flag and a woman is she's
generally positive and she's cheery
about life and work you also want to
look for a woman that's got some purpose
in life but she isn't a boss girl women
with purpose at boss girl level they're
a nightmare they're insufferable they're
they're always going to be
a real pain in your butt
you